Christian.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Heat. Heat.
Hey,
hey,
hey.
Christian.
Oh my god.
Hey everyone.
My name is Valerie Kellum. My pronouns
are she, her, and we're glad that
everyone's here. Before we get started,
we have a couple of announcements. And
coming up soon on the screen behind me
is going to be a QR code. And I'm going
to try and just say it one time. Y um if
you scan that, that's where you're going
to be able to find all of the
information I am about to tell you.
Next Sunday, March 8th, we're going to
be having a child dedication service. Um
at the table, we want to intentionally
partner with parents and families as
they're seeking to disciple their kids
in the way of Jesus and raise them up in
the midst of a loving community. So
again, all the information and signups
for this can be on the QR code. Um, so
if you want to sign up, you can go ahead
and scan that and sign up to have your
family participate.
Our next Sunday Unbound is going to be
Sunday, March 15th in the Family Life
Center, which is right behind this
building. And we're getting to focus on
what it means to be a community. And if
you want to contribute to the potluck,
again, you know what to do to sign up.
Finally, today is a Hat Creek Sunday.
So, after this service, please join us
at Hello Margot. This is Margot. Her
pronouns, as far as I know, are she,
her. Um,
join us at Hat Creek Burger in Saxi off
Highway 78. We uh will be there right
after church.
Also, we have an accessibility bucket.
It's just over here to my left.
Sometimes it can be hard to be in a
church setting. So, if you're feeling
anxious,
if you're feeling anxious about being in
here, you're part of the disability
community or just feeling a little extra
fidgety, you can stop by at any point
that accessibility bucket. There's noise
cancelling headphones, coloring sheets,
um fidgets, all things like that to help
you out. We just ask that you um return
anything you use at the end of service.
These candles here
to the side of me are a sign of the
presence of Christ among us. Fully
divine and fully human.
Now we exit the kingdom of noise, hurry
and productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness and simplicity.
sacred space,
a place for prayer, worship, and
adoration.
A place to behold, a place to behold
Christ, revelation of God, heartbeat of
creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you, to mend your heart. May we all
come home.
Thank you, Valerie and Margo. If you
guys want to stand with us, we're going
to start worship. And um this is just a
good reminder that we keep our kids with
us in for this first song. Not um just
to add an extra layer of excitement to
the beginning of our service, but um
because we do look for opportunities to
include them in the larger body of
Christ and not just segregate them to a
kid's classroom where they're always
separate and never seen, never heard.
Um, so we we want to embrace those
moments where our kids are with us,
where they are welcomed into the family
of God, where they know that they have a
place and a voice here. So I just wanted
to comment on that since we had the the
pleasure of an extra little one around
today. Um, and I want to open us up with
Psalm 148. Our first song is going to be
day for singing. And uh, this is sort of
the theme of it. Praise the Lord. Praise
the Lord from the heavens. Praise him in
the heights above. Praise him all his
angels, all his heavenly hosts. Praise
him sun, moon, all you shining stars,
you heights of heavens, and you waters
above the skies. Let them praise the
name of the Lord. Praise him from the
earth, you great creatures of the sea
and all ocean depth. Lightning and hail,
snow and clouds, stormy winds that do
his bidding. You mountains and hills,
fruit trees, cedars, wild animals,
cattle, small creatures and flying
birds, kings of the earth and all
nations. You princes and all you rulers
of earth, young men and maidens, old men
and children, let them praise the name
of the Lord, for his name alone is
exalted.
Let's sing out mercy.
The sea
rising with the rising of the sun.
Goodness
rushing in and filling up my lungs.
Your faithfulness
is here and now.
The evidence
is all around.
I bless your name. I give you praise.
Today is a day for singing.
Oh my soul. Come on and praise the Lord.
Sing.
Oh
my soul,
praise
the Lord.
Oh
my soul,
today is a day singing.
A new song
is well enough from deep inside me.
There is new life.
Hallelujah. I have been redeemed. I've
been redeemed.
I bless your name. I give you praise.
Today is a day for singing.
Awake my soul. Come on and praise the
Lord.
Today is a day singing.
Oh
my soul.
Praise
the Lord.
Oh
my soul,
today is a day for singing.
Today, today is a day for singing.
From the valley to the mountain, the
desert to the fountain.
Oh, I will praise you.
From the morning to the evening, as long
as I am breathing, today is a day for
singing.
From the valley to the mountain, the
desert to the fountain.
Oh, I will praise you
>> from the morning to the evening. As long
as I am breathing. Today is a day for
singing. Today, today, today is a day
for singing. Sing. I bless your name. I
bless your sing. I give you praise.
Today is a day for singing.
Awake my soul. Come on and praise the
Lord.
Today is a day for singing.
Sing. Oh my soul. Oh
my soul.
Praise
the Lord.
Oh
my soul,
today is a day for singing.
>> From the valley to the mountain, the
desert to the mountain.
Oh, I will praise the Lord.
From the morning to the evening, as long
as I am breathing, today is a day for
singing. Today, today
is a day for singing.
Today
>> All right, you kids are dismissed to go
to your classes with your teachers.
They'll meet you right over there by the
double doors. Thank you, kids ministry
team for loving on those little ones for
us.
And we're going to transition into
prayers of the people. Um if this is
your first time here, you can follow
along on the screens and we'll read the
sections that are in red out loud
together. And then we'll leave a space
um in the middle of the prayer for you
to speak out loud anything that you're
carrying into this space. And we want to
hold that up as a community together and
acknowledge um the weight that we
sometimes are carrying and uh believing
that God is also here with us in the
midst of that.
Jesus for this city of Saxi, Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them. We pray to you for the
good earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives, and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you
God for those in Iran
for families who lost children.
Johnny Owen
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts. We pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace, and a deep
sense of your presence. Amen.
Christ is my firm foundation,
the rock on which I stand when
everything around me is shaking.
I've never been more glad that I put my
faith in Jesus
cuz he's never let me down. He's
faithful through generations.
So why would he fail now?
He won't.
No, he won't. No, he won't.
I've still got joy in chaos.
I've got peace that makes no sense when
everything around me is under.
I'm not held by my own strength. Cuz I
built my life on Jesus
and he's never let me down. He's
faithful in every season.
So why would he fail now?
He won't.
He won't fail.
He won't
He will
He won't fail.
Christ is my firm foundation.
The rock on which I stand. when
everything around me is shaking.
But I've never been more glad. But I put
my faith in Jesus
cuz he's never let me down. He's
faithful through generations.
So why would he fail now?
>> He won't.
He won't.
He won't fail.
He won't
Rain came, wind blew, my house was built
on you,
and I'm safe with
you. I'm going to make it through.
>> Rain came, wind blew. My house was built
on you.
Now I'm safe with you. I'm going to make
it through.
Rain came, wind blew. My heart was built
on you.
And I'm safe with you. I'm going to make
it through.
>> Yeah. I'm going to make it through.
Cuz I'm standing strong on you.
Yeah.
>> I'm going to make it through.
Cuz my house was built on you.
>> Yeah. I'm going to make it through.
Cuz I'm standing strong on you.
>> Yeah. I'm going to make it through. Cuz
my house was built on you.
Are you hurting and broken thin?
Overwhelmed by the weight of your sin.
Jesus is calling.
Have you come to the end of yourself?
Do you thirst for a drink from the well?
Jesus is calling.
Oh, come to
the altar.
The Father's arms are open wide.
Forgiveness
was bought with
the precious blood of Jesus
Christ.
Leave behind your regrets and mistakes.
Come today, there's no reason to wait.
Jesus is calling.
Bring your sorrows and trade them for
joy.
From the ashes a new life is born.
Jesus is calling.
Oh,
come to
the altar.
The father's arms are open wide.
forgiveness
was bought with
the precious blood of Jesus Christ. Oh,
come to
the altar.
The father's arms are open wide.
forgiveness
was bought with
the precious blood of Jesus
Christ.
Oh, what a savior.
Isn't he wonderful?
Sing hallelujah.
Christ is risen.
Bow down before
him
for he is Lord
of all. Sing hallelujah.
Christ is ris.
Oh, what a savior.
Isn't he wonderful?
Sing hallelujah.
Christ is ris.
Bow down before
him
for he is Lord of all. Sing hallelujah.
Christ is ris.
So come to
the altar.
The father's arms are open wide.
Forgiveness
was bought with
the precious blood of Jesus Christ. So
come to
the altar.
The Father's arms are open wide.
Forgiveness
was bought with
the precious blood of Jesus
Christ.
Oh,
bear your cross as you wait for the
crown.
Tell the world all the treure you found.
The father's arms are open wide
for
the preious blood of Jesus Christ.
Come to
the altar.
>> The father's arms are open
for
the preious blood of Jesus
Christ.
God, what a reminder it is that you have
already come in your goodness, in your
faithfulness, in your forgiveness,
not for a perfect people, but for a
people who are faithful.
For those who are willing to keep
showing up,
for those of us who are willing to keep
opening up our hearts
in vulnerability, in honesty, in
authenticity,
for you to do your work in us,
for you to bring your love that
transforms us
into you who you created us to be, God.
into a people who are seen and known
and called.
God, would you tear down the walls that
we've built up against you? Would you
open our ears in the areas where we have
turned away?
Soften our hearts, God, where they've
grown weary and hard and exhausted.
God, would you come back in? God,
would you do your work?
God, would we live as those who are
loved?
and would we love others the way that
you have loved us.
Thank you that you've spread your arms
out wide open for each one of us
regardless of our past, our present.
You've invited us here to your table.
You've made room for us and our stories
and our mess.
God. So tonight we come
we come asking for more of you.
We come because of your love.
Thank you God.
And thank you for the gift of worshiping
together. It's in your name I pray.
Amen.
Would you guys turn to the person on
your right and left and say, "The peace
of Christ be with you." And then Brett
will get started on our message.
Grace and peace.
My name is Brett, pronouns he, him, and
uh it's good to be with you. Good to be
with you all. And uh that includes those
join us online. Love you all lots.
You're not forgotten. Glad you could be
with us through the wonders of the
internets. And uh yeah, anyone here
tonight who is new, thanks for for being
among us and uh yeah, having the courage
to come through those doors. So um let's
see. So, we're in the season of uh Lint
right now and I know Jesse kicked us off
um so well last week with his uh his
sermon and um so I didn't get to really
kind of intro Lent. So one of my little
caveats for I know you know
traditionally folks either kind of take
on a practice maybe you know some sort
of spiritual discipline or rhythm or
something maybe you know reading
scripture more you know having some time
for silence and prayer whatever um or
they will often like fast something you
know let go something give something up
um and I do want to name I would you
know I know we're already into it so
maybe I'm too late you know but if
you're if you decide to do something
with food I would say you know be
careful with that I think we Um, in the
modern world we have such a weird
relationship to food. Um, it's uh I mean
it's kind of most of it's like magical
food, you know, in the sense of it's
like it's uh science. It's a science
experiment, you know? I mean, it's made
to be like freaking delicious,
incredible. Like um like Cheetos.
Cheetos aren't good for me. I love
Cheetos. They're delicious. I don't know
what scientists cooked that up, but it's
amazing, you know? So, because this we
just have this weird, you know, we it's
just easy to get into like binge purge
cycles, you know what I mean? So, um, I
would kind of give you some caution with
with that. Um, but instead, you know,
maybe think of something else you could
could fast if, uh, if you haven't
already, you know, established your your
kind of Lenton rhythm. Um, so with that
in mind, the the title of my message
tonight is humans and transhumanists.
Um, for this series of Lint, we're not
necessarily have we don't have like one
theme exactly. Instead, we're following
the church lectionary. So, kind of like
the prescribed readings um, for each
week. This one's actually from last week
when I thought I would be uh preaching
last Sunday. Um so our um passage and
you can tell from this this is Genesis
2:es 15-1 17 and chapter 3:es 1-7. And
it's like very in the spirit of lint,
you know, it's like the the first humans
and the fall and and such. And um I I do
want to name you know the the kind of
the point of these stories from Genesis
is I think it's not so much you know
something like to be taken very
literally you know like often people
kind of pit this against like science
and whatever and then have a crisis of
faith you know um we actually know from
like modern scholarship that the the
book of Genesis these I mean the stories
can be quite ancient but like it really
wasn't especially this creation
narrative seems to be written around the
time of the Babylonian exile meaning
quite late in Israel's history. So, I
think for like the like a lot of the
early writers, I think they kind of knew
this wasn't, you know, necessarily
something like um kind of trying to
recount like literally exactly how God
brought the world into, you know,
existence. Um instead, I think the point
of these stories um is really to read
them not literally, but literarily, you
know. So, for example, sometimes like
the talking snake just like throws
people off, you know. It's like, yeah,
don't don't again don't get lost in the
literal level. Snakes can't do that. I
don't know. Um, read it literarily. Read
it as um as there is truth from the
spirit um to us, you know, through these
stories. Um so with that in mind, we can
begin in Genesis 2:es 15-17. The Lord
God took the man and put him in the
garden of Eden to work it and take care
of it. And the Lord God commanded the
man, "You are free to eat from any tree
in the garden, but you must not eat from
the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil. For when you eat from it, you will
certainly die." And then jumping on over
to chapter 3. Now the serpent was more
crafty than any of the wild animals the
Lord God had made. And he said to the
woman, "Did God really say you must not
eat from any tree in the garden?" The
woman said to the serpent, "Well, we may
eat fruit from the trees in the garden,
but God did say, 'You must not eat fruit
from the tree that is in the middle of
the garden, and you must not touch it,
or you will die." "Oh, you will
certainly not die," the serpent said to
the woman. For God knows that when you
eat from it, your eyes will be opened,
and you will be like God, knowing good
and evil." When the woman saw that the
fruit of the tree was good for food and
pleasing to the eye, and also desirable
for gaining wisdom, she took some and
ate it. She also gave some to her
husband who was with her and he ate it.
Then the eyes of both of them were
opened and they realized they were
naked. So they sewed fig leaves together
and made coverings for themselves.
So I want to focus in this u this
sermon. I want to reflect primarily on
the the language of the serpent there in
verses four and five where he says
you'll not certainly die. Um for God
knows that when you eat from it your
eyes will be opened and you will be like
God knowing good and evil.
uh when I kind of read this story,
what I well, I think there's a ton of
ways to interpret it, you know, it's
like almost endlessly like sort of any
good story, it's like endlessly
interpretable, you know, but one one
thing that jumps out at me is the kind
of uh almost a sense of throwing off,
you know, restraint like God kind of set
some boundaries there, you know, and
then we're just kind of like no, you
know, so there's this kind of, you know,
throwing off. It's uh the description
there in Genesis. It's almost like Adam
and Eve kind of begin in this very um
kind of dependent posture with God, you
know, almost childlike in its kind of uh
nature, you know. Um and uh God is, you
know, kind of the parent and it's like a
but he's like a good parent. Um but
it's, you know, but it's not like a
relationship of equals, you know. Um in
this story, obviously the Adam and Eve
like they don't they just don't know as
much. they don't know about as much
about the world um or yeah there's a
kind of naivity you know what I mean
around around uh both of them in the in
the narrative and um so you have this
kind of picture of Adam and Eve right in
this kind of parent child relationship
with God and then the serpent that's
what the serpent kind of you know
invites them to like hey you don't have
to be like that you know like throw
throw off um this is this kind of
rejection
of um kind of what we might call like a
creaturely, you know, dependence on on
God, right? To uh to be a creature in
essence means, you know, to be created,
right? Like you think of as as opposed
to the creator, right? The creator
creates, but like we are we're created.
We're um you know, I'm I'm not eternal.
Uh I'm not like somehow timeless, right?
I'm I'm not God. Rather, God brings me
and you and all things into being,
right? God creates. So that's creates
creatures.
And that's good. You know, that's good
and holy and beautiful.
Uh but it does leave us in a bit of a
precarious position, doesn't it? You
know, it's like we kind of have this
knowledge of like at one point I was not
and now I am.
And then some at some point I won't be
anymore, you know, or at least there's
that threat of, you know, death and the
end and you know, um that kind of looms
over us as creatures, you know. So
that's where I'm kind of using that
language of like creaturely dependence.
You that's kind of just the nature of
not even just humans, but like just to
be a creature is to be in this kind of
dependent um uh kind of posture. And I
think that's what, you know, that's what
the serpent is kind of playing on, you
know, like die. No, no, no, no, no.
You'll certainly not die. No, no.
Actually, the implication is God's kind
of holding out on you, you know, like
you could be like God. In other words,
like you can kind of transcend this
creaturliness.
You can you can know good and evil and
all that God knows. Ah but you can't do
that while remaining a creature you know
like you can't do that while kind of
remaining in this kind of this posture
of being like under God you know so
that's again that kind of restraint like
throw off those shackles throw off that
you know kind of restraint
so okay so what you know what what is
this what does this maybe mean for our
own day you know our own um kind of time
and uh what I want to do today is I want
to apply this to the realm of techn
technology. If you've been here at the
table for a while, you know, at least
like once a quarter, I'll just throw
like some sort of weird curveball
sermon, you know, this is definitely one
of those, you know, just like, wow, I
did not see this coming. Um, and I
tipped it off with the title, humans and
transhumanists. Um, so we're already
kind of hinting there like where we're
going. Um, so for the last like six
months or so, I have been like following
really closely the the work of like
techno optimists or optimists
um folks like uh in transhumanist folks
like Ray Kurszswe
um Peter Diamandis Alex Weezner Gross um
they have a podcast the moonshots
podcast they're tracking all the changes
in tech very closely so I've been like
listening to that and taking it in
really started kind of back in July when
I had a lot of time on my hands and uh
and read a book by Ray Kerszswhile and I
kind of heard of this you know out in
Silicon Valley like technoutopianism and
kind of the idea you know tech kind of
changing all all things for the good you
know and uh so I started kind of getting
into that and um and I I want to kind of
start by saying I really actually don't
want the sermon to come across like as
some sort of um I don't know almost like
a demonization of them or um or just a
like technology
in in general or as a whole. Um, so let
me kind of start with the good. I do
think they um and I can't speak for all
others, but at least these three. I do
think there's like good in their heart
in the sense of I do think they care
about humanity. I do think they see
suffering in the world and, you know,
would like it to end. Um, I know there's
other technoutopius folks who probably
are just using that language to like for
their own nefarious sense, you I'm not
saying like just trust all
technoutopians, but like at least these
three I did. I've listened to them a
lot. I've read a lot by them. And I do
think there's like a lot of goodness
there and um and they, you know, and
they believe technology can help, you
know, and I think if you look back
through human history, like there's
truth in that. Um I like that all of my
children have lived and we mostly expect
all of our children to live past the age
of five. You know what I mean? Like this
is a win. Um and uh you know so like I I
don't I think we have to be a little
careful of just kind of a negative you
know it's all technology is all crap and
we can't trust those people farther than
we can throw them and you know it's like
well um yeah there is there is good
there and uh I do think you know if you
put like put humans in a world of
scarcity
uh yeah it's not great you know you do
you get more wars uh you get a world
kind of red and tooth and claw and
really that's true of any organism you
know put a an organism in
a a creature so to speak, you know, in a
competitive resource scarce environment
and uh not going to be pretty, you know.
Um and at the same time, if you put
humans in a world of abundance, you
know, then hey, we we do are more likely
to find a way to like work out our
problems, you know, um without
bloodshed. So, yeah. So, so the point of
this message is not to be just, you
know, kind of flatly like
anti-technology. Um in the end, I do I
hope we cure cancer in many oral
disease. Um, I hope we can like extend,
you know, human health span and live
much longer and happier lives, you know,
than we do now. I I hope we find ways
to, you know, whether it's expanding
solar energy or something else and, you
know, lift the whole world out of
poverty by making energy too cheap to
meter. Uh, I hope we can create
massively affordable housing for
everyone. You know, I'm like, yeah,
sure, I'm down. I'm not I'm not against
these things, you know. Um so yeah I
think you know technology has um and can
do you know a lot of good for the world
and I don't think Christians you know we
need to be just purely kind of
reactionary and like live in just pure
fear you know of just tech and uh oppose
it at every turn right so in this sense
I'm I'm there is a side to me at least
that's kind of optimistic about um
technology and its role in the world and
at least when deployed well I think it
can ease human suffering. Um having said
that you know in the name of progress in
science and technology folks like
Kerszswe and Dian Mandis and Weezner
Gross um they I don't know they have
certain visions of the world and where
they would like it to go uh that I think
are um you know to put it gently I would
say it's they're overreaching that would
be the more academic kind of gentle way
the more kind of I guess normal way to
say it is I think they're crazy. I think
it's dangerous. I don't like this. Um,
and it's and it was when they start kind
of talking about transhumanism.
Um, really what they mean here is they
mean kind of a a post posthuman.
Um, so so what is transhumanism? It's
the belief that humans can ultimately
transcend creaturely limits by merging
with machines particularly at the level
of the mind. So, how did they like
propose doing this? I told you this is
going to be like a little bit out. Just
hang with me though. I am taking this.
It will I hope I can apply it to your
lives eventually. Um, so how do they
propose doing So, they're going to make
the idea is you'll you can't they don't
have the tech for this now, but the idea
is to make some sort of copy of the
brain and then upload human
consciousness
either into the cloud or into robotic or
posthuman or transhuman machine bodies
that can never die. So right in in short
the idea is uh we would no longer be
bound
by these kind of mortal
uh vulnerable fleshlike meat bodies. A
term I just hate every time they use
this term just like God. I even just
from branding alone. It's so stupid, you
know. But anyway, and instead, you know,
we'll merge with machines, right? Thus
becoming something kind of beyond or
after the homo sapiion, almost a kind of
a lowercase G god, you know, it's what
Uvuval Herrari in his book um calls homo
or uh calls it homous is his second book
to follow sapiens. Uh the the human god,
right? Um, now hopefully you can start
to see a little bit of like the
connection there between that and
Genesis 2 and 3, right? In the sense of
uh it's like a sort of a modern secular
version of you will surely not die. You
know, in fact, in fact,
you will be like God, you know, it's
like this is where as a as a reader of
the Bible, you know, my ears perk up
when I start hearing people, you know,
talk talk in these ways. Um, in fact,
Peter Denmen, he just wrote a new book
that comes out in a few months entitled,
we are as gods. So there you know
there's a there's an impulse here to
kind of throw off you know all restraint
and limitation and uh it is this kind of
alternative
techno secular kind of human salvation
you know but whereas in Genesis right
the serpent story it's like all very
hazy you know like no no just eat the
fruit it'll be great you know um in
their narrative it's pretty clear like
how this will happen right uh it's It's
it will be the marriage of you know it's
science and technology and future
breakthroughs and um how all that will
will play out. Now, the point of my my
sermon, it's not so much to like
say that I am skeptical of this idea of
like the transhuman and like make a copy
of the brain and like uploading human
consciousness and blah blah blah blah
blah blah, you know. Um although I am um
I think they I there's like a lot of
metaphysical claims there and philosophy
of mine. Like there's all sorts of stuff
that I'm just like that's going to be
impossible. That's never going to
happen, you know? Um but but still again
the point of my sermon isn't to like get
into those weeds of like let me tell you
why that's not even you know possible or
whatever. Um another topic I don't know
another day man it's not even another
topic for another day. It's probably
just you want to get coffee or something
we could talk about it you know but um
that won't be week two you know I could
do that next next week. Um,
instead my point is is simply
uh really to kind of say that you know
while transhumanists would say that
creaturely limits, you know, all those
things I was talking about earlier. Um,
being embodied and I can't be multiple
places at once and I don't know
everything. I'm not totally
self-sufficient. You know, I'm not
immortal like I can and will die. They
would say, you know, these are all like
these are negatives. These are bummers,
man. You know, like these are these are
downers and we've got to kind of break
out. we got to overcome these. Uh, and I
say, "No, no, no. I believe they're
actually intrinsic to being a creature
and should be embraced, respected, and
celebrated."
And, uh, and heck, I'll even, you know,
go a step further and say
that while they can have this vision,
they're really busy trying to like make
us, you know, lowercase G gods. Uh I
think the scriptures would say that
actually by God's grace we already in
some sense are right not in the capital
G sense but but in the sense that that
we already are like offshoots of the
divine. In fact we're already children
of God that you are already more than
this. You know what I mean? You're
already so it's almost like we're trying
to break out OF WE GOT TO GET OUT OF
THIS. WE GOT TO GET OUT OF THERE. WE'RE
TRAPPED in these vulnerable, you know,
and it's like, well,
uh, no, no, let leave that to God,
though, you know, um, yeah, because in
essence, when we die, we're not just
simply snuffed out, you know, but we do,
in fact, return to the God who is love,
where we're kept into eternity. So, if I
had to kind of, you know, sum all this
up, I would say like in this vision of,
you know, transhumanism, um, technology
replaces creaturliness,
control replaces trust, mastery
replaces, uh, receiving,
and uh, and aside from the kind of focus
on technology, I do think you get hints
of all of those in Genesis chapter 3,
right? The serpent tempts the humans
with this kind of vision, you know, of
independence and the temptation to kind
of control our own fate, right? That
temptation towards mastery and throwing
off, you know, all restraint. And you
know when I like think about the life
and example of Christ who was the very
you know son of God um yet even he like
didn't he embrace this kind of
creaturely dependence you know I mean
and taking on flesh and uh like like in
essence even he lived in dependence on
the one he called father you know even
he accepted human limitation and modeled
this kind of gracious receiving posture
you
receiving every moment, receiving um his
life as a a gift, you know, a gift to be
received, not something to be kind of
grasped and controlled, which
Philippians 2 um kind of gets into.
Okay, so you might say, you know, oh
yeah, okay, but aside from the I don't
know, one possibly zero transhumanists
in the room, you know,
what does this have to do with us? um
you know, does this really apply, you
know, to me in my life? Well, here's I
have kind of two thoughts on that. A I
want to preach on this because I do want
us to be prepared. I do want us like one
of our values, it's on some of your
shirts. You all got some the shirt with
the five values and the one of the first
one, right? Thoughtful. Thoughtful. This
is part of that value for
thoughtfulness. I'd rather like the
church tends to lag behind about 10
years, you know what I mean? And it's
kind of like after 10 years of
transhuman the church is finally like
okay we have a thought on this you know
just like yeah you're way late
everyone's formed there but you know so
I wanted to get kind of out in front
before most of you had even heard of
this idea to get us kind of thinking um
you know about it right to uh well
because I do think in the the coming
decade I do think we're going to
navigate a lot
of technological change
a lot uh like whatever you are imagining
10x it and then I think you're you start
start to you know get a little more of
what's coming and so in essence the
church we do like we need a kind of
theology of technology you know we need
like some thinking on this and uh yeah
and to really give it some time and
attention it deserves but it's not just
that it's not only just like well you
know I think in 10 years this will be
really relevant you know um I I I think
also want to say I want to preach on
this because I think we're already being
rendered more machineike.
I mean, think of we already spend most
of our days on machines, in machines,
working with machines, you know what I
mean? Like that's just especially these
things called computers. You might have
heard of them, you know, like this is
just our life, you know what I mean?
It's it's that in other words um I've
preached in the past maybe another one
of my kind of out there messages all all
about the the left and right hemispheres
of the brain in the book Ian McGill
Chrischrist that wrote by the master and
his emissary which talks about this that
in the modern world becoming more left
hemisphere dominant in the left
hemisphere is it's that kind of that
machine part of us it's that like
intensely linear logical kind of break
the problem down analyze analyze analyze
analyze analyze you know think it
through think it through and like in
essence that's a part of us like that's
one of the gifts we have. But in the
modern world, we just do more and more
and more and more and more of that, you
know what I mean? And all things kind of
the arts, you know what I mean? Like
that's all kind of like, well, in your
private time, you can do that for fun,
you know, but the vast majority of our
days are spent, you know, in machines,
working with machines, um, around
machines. And I think, you know, that
does something to us.
And and in essence, I think it does need
to be asked, you know, to what degree
uh is technology with its focus on
control and mastery, you know, of things
already kind of marginalizing our
creaturely humanity, you know, all
that's kind of soft and fleshly and
bodily and emotional and relational.
Does that make sense?
like and and yes, you know, although
this sermon is not about artificial
intelligence, it kind of is, you know,
um again, not in the kind of simple
binary of like AI good, AI bad, which is
sort of what everyone's doing
politically right now. Um I I think um I
think we just have to kind of critically
ask the question, you know, um yeah, how
is how is this tech being deployed? How
how what is it what is it doing to us?
Um how is it impacting us? How will it
play out kind of socially?
Um
what's it doing to me, to my community,
to the world? Uh for example, I heard
the actor Ethan Hawk uh being
interviewed just outside of a theater
and um he said this. He said, "I'm so
bored by AI. One of the things I love
about the theater," and then he kind of
gestured to like the double doors, which
behind him was a theater. It's like is
that AI can't do it. And I feel I just
couldn't be less interested in computers
and fake things. I like people. I like
the way they smell. I like the way they
talk. I like the way they think. I know
AI is going to change the world.
Screwing everybody up. I'm not in denial
about that, but I am in open rebellion.
You know, now what's he getting at
there? Um the the thing I really like
about that is he's he's trying to
emphasize that kind of that humanness.
You know what I mean? That's where like
for me personally, my kids think I'm
obsessed with artificial intelligence
and stuff. you know, they're like, "Dad,
you they said, "Dad, would you be so sad
if AI went away?" And I was like, "Oh,
uh, no." I said, "I think you
misunderstand." I'm like, I'm fascinated
by its implications by like what that
means, you know? Um, but I'm really in
terms of personally, I only care about
it to the degree that actually makes a
more humane world. I mean, to the degree
it frees people up to live more human.
Oh, I'm very curious, you know, how we
do this. to the degree that it makes
everyone kind of renders everyone more
machine-like or renders society more
machine-like. I'm just kind of like, you
know, I'm pretty much with Ethan Hawk
there, right? And and I think there is
something um I don't know, there's
something that sounds very wholesome and
even Christian in the best sense of the
word in Hawk's quote there, right? I
mean, I could imagine Jesus saying, "I
like people,
you know, I like the way they smell. I
like the way they talk. I like the way
they think. I'm interested in that. You
know, this is this seems very Christlike
to me. And I mean, in essence, he's what
he's getting at is I like creatures.
I like creatures,
you know, and I personally I like being
a creature
and I embrace it.
And I think that's really the task for
Christians in the 21st century, probably
this decade in particular, to really
become more creaturely,
not less. That's what I'm like kind of
begging us like I know again kind of
with I know AI is going to change the
world, all the things, all the tech and
all the visions and all this, you know,
I know it's going to change. It is it's
lots of change coming. Okay. But I'm
just begging us like let's not lose um
our kind of love of creatures and our
own creaturliness. You know, let's fall
more in love with creatures and
creation, not less. And yeah, machines
have their place, you know. Again, my
point isn't just to demonize all that,
but but but the point of technology,
it's always to serve creatures, you
know, not ser creatures, to serve
technology.
And I think that's not uh that's not
something we can or should forget.
In the name of the Father, the Son, and
the Holy Spirit. Amen.
Well, on the night Jesus was betrayed,
he had one final meal with his
disciples. And at that meal, he held a
loaf of bread and he broke it. And he
said, "Take this, eat. This is my body
broken for you." And then he held up a
cup of wine. He said, "Take this drink.
This is my blood. It's shed for you.
Whenever you eat this bread, whenever
you drink this cup, remember me. So, as
we come forward tonight, we we come
forward as embodied creatures taking in,
right? It's a very um bodily, physical,
material kind of act. And this is how we
connect with God, you know, it's not by
like flying off to the heavens or
something. It's it's like here as the
creatures God made us um to be. So, the
way we'll go about this, we'll just
start here on the front row and just go
row by row forming one line in the
middle. Uh we practice an open table.
So, if you're here tonight and you want
to participate, then you're free to do
that. Uh, just know the red is wine, the
white is grape juice. And finally, you
can just partake whenever and however
you'd like. Some folks take immediately,
some like to come and kneel, but however
you want to partake of the elements is
totally up to you. So, this is the
table, not of the church,
but of the Lord, and it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more. So come, come you
who have much faith and you who have
little. You who have been here often and
you who have not been here long. You who
have tried to follow and you who have
failed. Come. Come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you. And it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here. Come to the table.
We're going to close with a hymn um that
you may have heard before called This Is
My Father's World. And just in the
spirit of remembering and celebrating
this life that is embodied, this life
that we do live as creatures on a planet
that is spinning around a sun with with
other creatures around us and um and
finding the beauty there, finding the
tension that we hold in this limited um
physical realm and and celebrating that
God is here with us, that he gave us
this life, this one wildlife to live
together. Um, so if you guys would stand
with us as we close out tonight and sing
these words if you know them, they'll be
up on the screens as well.
This is my father's
world
and to my listening
ears.
All nature
sings and round me rings
the music
of the spheres.
This is my father's
world.
I rest me in the thought
of rocks and trees, of skies and seas.
His handling
wonder.
This is my mother's
world.
The birds their cars
raise
the morning
light. The valley
declare their maker
praise.
This is my mother's
world.
She shines in all that's fair.
There
grass I hear her pass. She speaks to me
everywhere.
This is my father's
world.
Oh, let me never forget.
And though the wrong seems are so
strong,
God is love.
Yeah.
>> Though the wrong seems are so strong,
God is the ruler.
Yeah.
>> This is my father's
world.
Why should my heart be?
>> The Lord is king. Let the heavens
ring.
God reigns. Let the earth be glad.
>> The Lord is king. Let the heavens
re
>> God reigns. Let the earth be glad.
joining us this evening. If you are new,
we would love to have you fill out a
card that's on the table to the left
just so we can know that you were here.
Um, another way is you can scan this
infamous QR code that should be coming
up on the screens behind me. Um, we
would just love to know that you were
here with us. Um, we could all use some
more relational support and the way that
we do that here at the table is through
our groups called meetups. Um, again, if
you are scanning that QR code, you can
find a Meetup group that is close to
your location.
Generosity is a key aspect of a life of
adoration and worship. Um, if the table
is your church home, we would invite you
to give financially. Again, you can do
that through that lovely QR code or you
can go to the tabletx.org.
All right, let me send you into your
week with this benediction. You can hold
out your hands in a posture to receive
or you can just open your heart to these
words.
You are a child of God.
You are a child of God. This is true on
your best day and it is true on your
worst.
So as you go into your week with its yet
to be determined highs and lows, go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved,
you are worthy,
and you are accepted exactly as you are.
And go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend the same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come into contact with.
Thank you guys so much and remember
we'll be at Hat Creek.
>> This is my father's
world.
Why should my heart be sad?
>> The Lord is king. Let the heavens
ring.
God reigns. Let the earth be glad.
>> The Lord is king. Let the heavens
ring.
God reigns. Let the earth be glad.